many people
will have seen already but we are going
to show a couple of these videos
in which uh people who
are calling themselves black lives
matter protesters
are approaching and being antagonistic
towards restaurant goers so zach if you
want to show
the first video from matt walsh
[Music]
[Applause]
down
[Music]
and we have another one to show but
before we move on uh for those who were
who are listening only and not watching
you see
one particular young woman yelling at
two restaurant goers
and uh what has happened i think before
the recording started
is uh that the the mob has shown up and
demanded of all of these people most of
whom are eating outside
uh that they raise a fit in a fit
there is a fist in solidarity and uh we
see
other people everyone else that we can
see uh who's seated at this restaurant
has raised a fist in solidarity
uh i would again refer to those as you
know don't hurt me fists
uh some of them will feel like they're
in solidarity but this is this is the
green grocer this is the don't hurt me
uh salute vox love hovels green grocer
uh and you also see some of the
protesters mobsters in the foreground at
the end of the video
not raising a fist but giving a finger
to uh the two
the couple the the young straight white
couple uh those last two descriptives of
which
shouldn't matter at all uh who are
refusing to do what the mob has demanded
of them
so let's show this uh first this tweet
barry weiss
um we we found this one through barry
weiss zach
and then if we could show the video
that's embedded in there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peace
so very much the same kind of scene in
this case it looks like it's just
a woman maybe maybe she's sitting with
someone we don't see them
uh being
assaulted by a group of people including
particular
a young man a young white man who is
just gets
right up in her face very aggressive
very
very in any other situation i would say
that was clearly a sexed interaction
in which a dude is aggressively going
after
a woman who is sitting there and not
having any of it she too is not raising
a fist
so barry after um barry weiss after
posting that video
uh she she got from another source says
also makes me wonder what makes
particular people brave enough to stand
up to a mob
is it a rare personality is it strong
conviction that overrides the fear
and she asks if we might have any
insight
and before we start talking about that
i think this is a good time to bring up
again as i think we did in the last
episode that famous
uh martin niemoller i need to look up
his name to make sure i'm pronouncing it
correctly
uh quotation uh from
you know about and after world war ii
in which he says first they came for the
socialists and i did not speak out
because i was not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i did
not speak out because i was not a jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me
and i tried to modify that
uh exquisite and unfortunately doesn't
go out of fashion
uh poem from him last time and i didn't
really nail it and someone
on youtube who goes by bobby b fat
did what i think is a better job so
here's his contribution
first they came for the socialists and i
helped them because i am not a socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i helped them because i am not a
trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i helped
them because i am not a jew
then they came for me because they no
longer needed my help
at the end it's very frightening because
to the extent that
they came from me you know what they
come from me is
right that's death and the fact that
there is no one to stand between you and
it is frightening
and the fact that you don't understand
that you lost your opportunity
to be defended at the point that you
failed to defend it's such an obvious
point at one level and then
we see the game theory fail again and
again and again for you know exactly the
reasons that barry
is asking us if we have insight into
but i wanted to go back to something
about the video yes you said
that they were asked to raise a fist in
solidarity
i am i am inferring that from comments
and such i don't think i don't think i
heard that in the videos
i think it is exactly the inference you
are supposed to take and the thing is it
is simultaneously true and a lie
right solidarity with what it is true
that that is
presumably what they were asked to do
but is that actually
are those words actually reflective of
what the gesture would mean
is is that is that the way in which it's
a lie it's a lie in exactly the same way
that asking people to kneel right we've
seen many
in the early parts of the protests and
riots we saw officials being asked
to kneel with the protesters kneeling is
you know did you kneel you know is this
kneeling as in the game of thrones
you are showing failty to something is
this kneeling in solidarity it's totally
ambiguous and so the point is
it is a physical mountain bailey where
the gesture has both characteristics
now if i raise a hand a physical
motivation it's a physical mountain bail
if i raise a fist
right like this in solidarity with black
lives matter
have i announced that i believe
that black lives are undervalued and
that we have to do something about it or
have i just embraced black power which
is of course traditionally what that
fist
is now i'm not even against the idea
that a fist raised for black power is
inherently an offensive thing
i i get it but the idea that you're
gonna
accost people and force them
to make a gesture that very plausibly
means that they are in favor of a black
power movement
right with no discussion that this is
and i guess i would say we can it's even
easier than that
i don't care what it is that a mob shows
up at a restaurant asking me to do
i don't you know if it's if it's a if if
it's demanding that
i show support for a movement that i
myself found it right
why is it that anyone
should feel responsible to or forced to
do that thing no matter how firmly they
are convinced that they are actually
in favor of that thing and so i mean
these really are two separate questions
right
this thing that they're asking you to do
is not what it seems and it's obscuring
a whole lot of other things and actually
you can tell that by the fact of how
they're behaving right here right now
but also even if you're sure the thing
that you were being asked to show
support for is something that you
support
you should always be free to show or not
show support for that thing on your own
terms under your own conditions on your
own time
and and so we have these few
restaurant goers resisting even while
everyone around them
is sort of looking a little bit shamed
and doing this thing
and how will
how will the people who resisted versus
the guy sitting next to them who didn't
resist
feel how did they feel that night how
did they feel afterwards the people who
resisted
were probably shaken yeah still scared
worried could they be doxxed could they
be found
but they knew that they had resisted the
thing
that demanded of them something that was
not okay
and the guy who avoided the mob for now
how what does he do does he sleep does
he sleep well
i don't think so there's he and there's
those off camera and this is we we have
to
we have to go yeah yes so um
i agree with your formulation and i
think it's exactly right if
if a group of well-intentioned people
confronted us at a cafe surrounded by
people
maybe they came to us and they said you
know so do you support unity 2020
we'd say of course and then they start
uh
you know forcing other people to embrace
it in the cafe suddenly
i'm not even on board with the support
part the point is i don't support it if
it's forced
in any way um and
all right so let's get to the i think
it's really in part the issue
that barry is asking us to comment on
which is what happened the people on
camera those who
put up their fists and those who
resisted that's one category and we
because of our evolutionary processing
focus on that because they are the
people in the narrative but this
narrative
is really not even about them right the
person who sees that video which is
who knows hundreds of thousands of times
as many people
as were actually present maybe millions
depending upon how far those videos go
that's the target and i will point out
this is the exact analog
of the evergreen situation right the
protesters flooded in cameras out
right the idea is whatever you do is
about to be broadcast
who do you want to be right now
let's compare these two on the screen
you've got
the people who raised their fist did
what they were told irrespective of what
they actually felt
right they paid one price maybe they
weren't comfortable being told to raise
their fist and they felt weak for doing
so on the other hand there's no focus on
them
right they are unlikely to show up
anywhere
um on the other hand they may walk away
sorry i know you're going somewhere but
they may walk away
actually and some of them may walk away
feeling better about the movement
because they have now shown support and
it will be harder for them to walk away
and some of them and unfortunately i
think it will be a minority
will walk away feeling worse about the
movement now questioning it in a way
that they perhaps had not done before
and wonder if it can do that
to people who had nothing to with whom
they had no beef
um what else might it do and they might
uh they might actually begin to question
the movement i suspect though that will
be a minority
of those who without thinking about it
and without ever imagining that they
would resist
didn't resist and did raise a fist and
support well i will say again
evergreen teaches us everything we need
to know um there was a
faculty colleague of ours somebody who
at one point would have called
a friend who was cornered during
the protests at evergreen and was
frightened by it and wrote about it
and then flipped sides because she was
offered
power in exchange for embracing the
thing which is of course
the underlying dynamic here but oh yeah
all right if we
if we go back to this these cafes
right if you don't raise a fist in that
circumstance
then you are very likely you have reason
to expect
that video of you not raising a fist is
going to be broadcast
so whether or not you are doxxed
is in some sense not it because the
the price to be paid for raising a fist
is probably a price between you and who
you were sitting with because they're
you know that's the person you have to
look in the eye after the thing
the person who didn't raise a fist
whatever their reason for not doing so
may have been and it may have been as
good as the one you spell out
maybe the point is hey you're not going
to tell me when i raise a fist and when
i don't i will decide that this is in no
way a statement about your movement
right this is a statement about you not
being able to tell me what i do
right it's a statement about us being
equals right it's a statement
about uh maybe i'm an ally but i'm an
ally by virtue of
the real meaning of that term which is a
pure relationship not a subordinate
relationship
and so in this case solidarity which
sounds like a pure relationship
is actually subordination but in any
case
think about the asymmetry of the game
theory you're one of the anonymous
people who raised their hands
it doesn't get very far maybe nobody
even spots that you were present
okay right you're the person who doesn't
raise your hand
suddenly you're raised you're you're
suddenly famous for this
right in some sense right you are
not now on the minds of all of the
people who think it's cool to go to
cafes and force people to raise a fist
right you're you're on their feet as one
of the resistors
and you're also broadcast everywhere
else and so
this is the answer to your question
barry is that the game theory plays out
in the mind
in that moment with the what do i do
to reduce the cost of this thing maybe i
don't want to empower
this movement i don't want to become its
iconic resistor
i don't want this to dominate my life
going forward
the point is the bargain is you do
whatever minimizes the chance that the
camera lands on you
but you're answering the inverse
question that she asked well she's
asking what makes particular people
brave enough to stand up to a mob so you
are you are explaining
and this also warrants explanation it
warrants both the question being asked
and it being answered what explains the
vast majority of people and i've seen
numbers in the range of like 98 99
of people who will um who will raise the
fist
um and you know we have that that is the
answer you are providing right now but
really what we need is to provide people
not just
sort of a litany of you might have these
characteristics in which case you might
be more likely to resist
such demands should a mob come for you
but also
what is it that you can be thinking of
in the moment that will allow you to
have the courage in the moment to resist
all right but this is where this gets so
complicated i agree with you that the
question i answered is the inverse of
the question she asked but it also
i think contains the indicator of the
question of the answer to the question
she did ask
unfortunately this is personal it'd be
much better if
i wasn't the guy in those evergreen
videos
the thing that people need to understand
and i keep saying it and i think people
don't quite get what i'm
saying
why did i do what i did confronted with
students armed with cameras portraying
me as a racist
who wanted me to simply embrace their
movement
publicly so that they would go away and
harass someone else
there was never a choice it never
occurred to me literally did not occur
to me that
that was an option on the table still
doesn't i still
i know formally it's an option on the
table but i do not
register it as one because something
about my
development produced a program in which
that's just not an option on the table
right it's like a keyboard without an
accent on it
right there may be some keystroke you
could use to get there but it's not on
the keyboard but help everyone else out
here like how how do other people
without that
very particular and you know perhaps
unique
in the world uh trait that doesn't even
register
going along as an option even for a
moment how
do the rest of us not only dismiss that
as an option
in the moment but really just relegate
it to to the netherworld
so i'm not ruling it out what i'm saying
is
the thing that you're looking for is the
answer
whatever it was that developmentally
produced and it's not it's not just me
it's lots of people but it's rare i've
never heard anyone else describe
exactly what you're saying because you
know there are there are there are many
of us who
will stand up to these things but the
way that you describe this
is so absolute and that kind of
absolute like actually you don't have to
worry
in the moment about what choice you will
make because actually there is no choice
uh is a kind of framing that might be
useful for some people who might
otherwise find themselves unsure
how it is that they should need to act
in the moment
so there is development
and then there are hacks that substitute
for development and
i think the question that people are
really asking and i do get asked this a
fair amount
i think the thing that people they don't
know when i was teaching i always used
to say
to students please answer the question i
should have asked you rather than the
one i did ask you
because very often students will answer
the question you did ask when the right
question is right next door and you'll
discover it a week later and so
i'm going to answer the question that
people should ask which is how do i
bootstrap the developmental
structure to get there because i know my
logical mind knows that that's who i
want to be
how do i override the amygdala in the
moment
and do the right thing right and i would
argue that this is actually
a this is something i i don't know how
they do it in the military but the
military
manages to take people and reschedule
their system of incentives so that they
are capable
of effectively being ordered to engage
in heroism or something like this
and i'm not arguing that that's the
right structure here but my point is
unfortunately there's also a certain
degree of depersonalization
and yeah and such that is not what we
would be i would want to be seen as
advocates that's why
it's why it's not the right answer in
this case but what it is is a proof of
concept
that there is an answer to this question
that can be systematized now i'm not
arguing for a systemic answer and in
fact the poem
that you read about first that came from
the socialists
yeah first they came for the socialist
is
uh a it is a
hack to the extent that you have that
thing resident in your mind
some part of you actually knows that
thing so the question is does that
thing arise in your mind at the point
that they you know come for you
so i mean that is that is one of the
things that poetry is for right
that because because it's inverse it's
easier to call up it's easier to have
remembered in the first place and it
is more likely to come up into your mind
at the point that a mob shows up
right and the other thing is an analog
i've argued
in a couple places i think i did an
early video on um
wisdom and i argued something that then
after i released my video i
turns out a lot of people have made an
argument similar to this in various
different places but the argument is
that wisdom is either very tightly
related with
or synonymous with delayed gratification
that the idea is we are all as children
uh unable to regulate our desire to have
that
thing and that there are many things
that in order to have the thing you
really want
you have to be able to forego some
superficial substitute for it in the
short term yeah
am i i think i think the marshmallow
test somehow got to
get revealed as not being what it was
claiming to be
but um but it still looms large for me
as an example of this god it's so noisy
out there today um
so yes whether or not the marshmallow
test is or is not valid like the
stanford prison
experiment may or may not be valid it
resonates
because we all know that there's
something to this and we all watch
children unable to regulate their desire
for that thing and foregoing something
much better and so
the adults we respect are almost always
people who have figured out
how to put off some
instant gratification for a delayed
gratification and the farther you can
delay that gratification
the more powerful this process is and
frankly the thing that's
really hard to grasp is that our
society has caused us
to become very deeply focused
on self as individual and this is
understandable
but as important as self is
self is also part of something right how
important
is yourself if the things that you do to
keep yourself
you know we're watching uh people of
means fleeing
major cities even as they are
politically paralyzed from doing
anything interesting
right they're saving themselves and they
are not taking any risk
on behalf of the larger entity on which
we all depend
that is going to result sooner or later
in that
entity failing and we are actually you
know when you're watching americans
confronting other americans in cafes and
portraying them as uh racist or
otherwise
uh defective for not being willing to
comply with an order
um you're watching the failure of of the
u.s and so the point is
registering the value of that which
is lost if you act in the moment in the
way
that you are being incentivized to act
is the key
can you do no no i i gotta i gotta push
back against it's far too analytical
like there's no way that it works at
that level in part because
um you know what you're saying is you're
you're
people are thinking too much about
themselves and not enough about
something bigger
and i would argue it's actually exactly
the opposite that people that this you
know what
what is it that some people have that
allows them to stand up to a mob
well um having this character trait of
being ash negative
which is something that your brother has
talked about and we have talked about
before right like
of of not conforming to expectations of
the people around you when they are
patently lying
right so that's what the ash experiment
from the
50s revealed and later repeats there
have been
hundreds i think of replications of that
and that was originally just male
undergraduates and it's been done
now in you know across a number of of
people and
one of the things we find for instance
is that women are more likely
to fall prey to the ash confort the
conformity
of of peer pressure basically uh even
when these peers who are new to them
and they will probably never see again
and they are patently telling a
falsehood about what it is they see
before them
women are more likely than men to to
conform
and that doesn't mean that all women can
form and no men conform
nor does it mean that you can't change
yourself but sort of
recognizing conformity to peer pressure
to social pressure
as something that you are engaging in in
the moment when the mob is there
and saying you know what no who am i you
know who who
am i when i go back and try to sleep
tonight
and report out to my spouse or my god or
my children or my friends whatever it is
will i be proud to look them in the eye
and say this is what i did or will i
look at the ground the way the guy
sitting next to the resistors is with
his fist in the air
knowing that he does not want to look at
the camera but i don't understand
i understand everything you just said
and of course i resonate with it what i
don't understand is where the
disagreement is because i feel like
we're talking about the same thing
i think in the moment it's it's so easy
it's too easy
to be be in that room i mean
so this is this is maybe maybe the
framing
is as you have said many times elsewhere
uh the room is not the room right the
room is in fact the
the internet where this thing is getting
going to get get played out
but in the moment in the room our
understandable
millions of years of human and in
pre-human evolution
cause us to look around and try to fit
to some degree
especially if some are threatening
violence against us
how do you just get out of this
situation right now
you are asking for people to imagine
maybe a bigger
us a a bigger
group that will be better served um by
resistance but that requires staying
in the group think and and
and sort of moving through the emotion
into a purely analytical purely abstract
space
that also doesn't refer back to who you
are at your core identity
and i think you know i think that those
two sort of extremes
of who you are as an individual and who
you are proud to be and who you want to
aspire to be
and how successful are you being
at becoming that best of all possible
use
and how is it that society can
be best for all people that those are
the two
things that that we would we would try
to maximize
and that intermediate social group is
the one that is most likely to get you
to behave
badly and i just i think that
in the moment referring back to yourself
and your individual self and and whether
or not you're going to be able to
live with yourself is going to be much
more likely to succeed
than imagining the the greater
abstraction
okay now i know why we're disagreeing
okay um
let's imagine three states there's self
which is local in space and time to me
there's future self which is local to me
but not in time that is to say how am i
going to feel
an hour after this interaction how am i
going to feel a year after this
interaction
and then there's self but bigger that is
to say i'm part of something that i'm
actually dependent on
and uh ultimately if that thing fails
the cost to me is absolute
right i think all of i think all these
things are the same
they result in the same alteration of
um of the thought process
in the moment and um i would just
point out and let's take the evergreen
situation because it was simple and
because we know the context of it
right i didn't have a choice i wouldn't
have had a choice if i had been alone
but i was also there in front of my
students right
for me to have a choice in that moment
would have left me
uh completely hypocritical with respect
to everything i had represented to them
as true that doubly made it no choice
you had already publicly defined
yourself
as who you were on the inside and
therefore to to to cave to the mob would
have been a public act of hypocrisy
which won't be true for most people and
so maybe one of the things you're
arguing is
in advance of any such mob coming for
you begin to make public in small ways
who you know yourself to be
so that you have to answer to the self
that you've already established yourself
to be
i believe this is exactly correct and
the reason people don't do it in general
is that they will begin to lose friends
and
yes this goes we are hearing from many
of them
this goes to something you and i have
said on multiple occasions which is that
one thing
that was crystal clear about the
evergreen situation
was that it revealed everybody's
character
now the fact is the people that i might
have thought were our friends
who turned on us i would rather not have
had them as
acquaintances in the run-up to the thing
because what they were
was unreliable and what you need is
friends who are reliable so better to
know
it's better to know as early as possible
and so to the extent
that you see so sad but it's better to
know um
the only thing i find sad about it is
their failure of character
right the fact that though that weakness
is so widespread
is sad i don't find it personally sad
i'm i mourn the narrative that i thought
was true
i i agree and i'm stunned by some of the
things we saw
but i would say the other side of that
is not well you're going to lose friends
it's you're going to discover who you
can trust who you could
find yourself in a foxhole with and be
glad that they were the ones
there and so faculty almost universally
disappointed us they didn't all turn on
us
right many of the people that we were
friends with were
silent which is frustrating or privately
supported or privately supported but
they did not
attack us there were attacks from a
number of different people
but the number of people especially on
the student side who shined
right was more than compensation for all
of the people who
were weak and so i think i think you're
right that the way
the hack that is useful is to explore
this
ahead of time such that the structure
that is there at the point that you are
confronted with that camera
knows why you did what you did um
so two other things i think we should
say is one
i don't see any reason to imagine that
the people who didn't raise their fist
had the slightest bit of racism to them
but even if they did the point is this
is not
how we interact with each other right it
is one thing to disagree with people it
is another thing
to weaponize stigma
in order to control them that is
completely unacceptable
it is uh obviously a threat that's being
leveled
in public and we all have an absolute
obligation
to resist uh its being
wielded right no good will come of this
and it certainly will not be good for
black lives or any
any other group of americans